foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar the
evolution of carbon fixation studying
Form 1 rubisco using ancestral sequence
reconstruction and Mass photometry
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by refine to learn more visit refine.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Luca
Schultz doctoral researcher Max Planck
Institute for terrestrial microbiology
Luca you may now begin your presentation
hello everybody and thanks for the nice
introduction
um I hope you can hear me just fine uh
I'm here today to talk about our recent
study about the evolution of increased
complexity and specificity to Donovan
from one rubiscos
and um I'll dive right right into it
basically the main question that we set
out to answer in the very beginning when
I started my research was not so much
focused on rubisco itself but rather
about the evolution of complexity in
proteins in general
um specifically about the evolution of
obligated heterological mirrors
um and here we were mostly interested or
intrigued by the observation that many
proteins assemble into obligated
oligomers
um so proteins that are composed of
different distinct subunits encoded by
you know distinct genes such as in a
very simple case for example rubisco
which is composed of two distinct
subunits one large and one small subunit
which I'll come to in more detail in a
bit
but there's also very extreme examples
of this such as for example ATP synthase
that contains of diff 17 different
subunits that all have to come together
to form this very intricate molecular
machine
and oftentimes these obligates
heterological mirrors actually evolve
from less complex ancestors that
actually didn't contain as many subunits
as these molecular machines contain in
present-day organisms
um
basically for any obligator oligomer
that we observe in nature
um there's very often the case where in
bacterial genomes or in just related
genomes we can find ancestral forms of
the same protein complex that is a base
that is a bit less complex and then over
a certain interval of evolution a new
subunit was gained
but then also presumably over the same
interval of evolution this new
interaction eventually became essential
for the complex
and oftentimes this actually happens
without a real change in the function of
the complex it might become slightly
better but this is often not really
visible or not easily decipherable
so it actually becomes really difficult
to decipher the function of this novel
subunit
um and a further reason as to why this
is actually pretty difficult for these
innocuous small interaction partners
that are strictly essential for an
oligomer
is that if you now take this essential
subunit away your protein complex of
choice would be insoluble or
non-functional
and uh with this we pose two questions
the first is just Why do such new
interactions evolve especially if
there's not really any obvious
functional associated with these novel
subunits
um is there a good way to decipher the
function of such a subunit and why do
proteins suddenly start to depend on a
subunit that they're newly recruited
into a complex you can imagine that this
could just be an interaction that
doesn't necessarily have to become
essential
um and for this we decided to retrace
the evolution of rubisco as our model
obligator complex in the lab and to try
and answer these questions
I'm just a very brief introduction on
rubisco itself
um rubisco stands for ribos one five
bisphosphate so this is this substrate
here this is a sugar substrate that is
diphosphorylated
um one for a business carboxylase
oxygenase and its main function in
nature is that it carboxylates uh
ribosome bisphosphate to produce two
molecules of three phosphoglycerate
and a substance reaction is the core
reaction of the Calvin cycle which is
used by for example autotrophic
organisms to fix carbon dioxide
and prominent members of autotrophic
organisms that use the carbon cycle are
for example plants and algae that are
all around us and use rubisco to obtain
its biomass to fix carbon dioxide
in these organisms rubisco forms this
very typical L8 S8 so this is eight
large and eight small small subunits
complex that I've already alluded to
earlier
uh which for the sake of my presentation
I will mostly be representing in this
schematic
um where the large subunits are these
sort of bean shaped subunits that form a
ring
and then there's four small subunits
sitting on top of this octometer of
large subunits and four small subunits
sitting at the bottom of this this ring
of large subunits and the small serving
is sort of serve to cap this complex
in rubisco the small subunit is
non-catalytic
um so there's also no real obvious
function associated with it
um but it is strictly essential and I
should mention it's the reason why
there's no obvious function associated
with it is first of all because it is
essential that you can't easily take it
away and decipher its function
by simple experiments in the lab but
then also because the smart surveillance
is actually not in direct contact with
the catalytic Center of rubisco at all
it's in fact it's about 20 to 25
angstroms away from it
and also with this and this makes
rubisco a good model system for our
study here um the small subunit of
rubisco is known to be an evolutionary
novelty so if you look into the genomes
of organisms which we know acquired
rubisco earlier than plants or algae we
can see that over the course of
evolution
rubisco transitioned from being a simple
dimer of large subunits to eventually
become an becoming an octometer of large
subunits that then eventually
Incorporated the small subunit and
formed this canonical or this very
typical L8 S8 complex which in total
contains 16 subunits
um as I've already mentioned the small
subunit's role is not really known
um yet there were some guesses as to
what it might be evolved in involved in
and this comes from the observation that
these L8 S8 rubiscus are mostly found in
organisms that occupy aerobic habitats
whereas all the rubiscus that are in
organisms or all the rubiscus that don't
form a complex with the small subunit
are typically found in anaerobic
organisms
um
and now
why this might be important or what this
muscle unit might be involved in
um for this is it's important to know
that rubisco can actually catalyze a
second reaction in which it doesn't take
carbon dioxide as its substrate but
instead it mistakingly reactive oxygen
and incorporates oxygen
this leads to a process called
photorespiration in which the two
phosphoglycolate which is produced from
the oxygenation reaction has to be
metabolized or detoxified in a reaction
that releases carbon dioxide and ATP
and now people have presumed that the
small subunit might be involved in
modulating rubisco's so-called
specificity factor which is a measure of
how specific A rubisco is for its gases
substrates and how good it is at
discriminating CO2 from O2
um however the sole evidence for this is
basically the fact that the L8 S8
rubiscus are most defined in Aerobic
habitats where oxygen is present and the
rubisco complexes that incorporate a
small subunit are typically more
specific
um whereas those complexes that don't
contain a small subunit are mostly found
in anaerobic environments where there's
no Oxygen present
all right now with this we set out to
answer essentially the questions that I
posed earlier why did the small subunit
evolved and what uh and what is its
function and why is it now essential
when it wasn't in the past
um for this and I'm not going to break
this down in four further questions that
I'm going to be answering in sort of the
next few slides we first wanted to
basically find The evolutionary interval
over which the small subunit evolved so
that we can then retrace its evolution
um for this we built a phylogeny and in
a very very broken down schematic way a
rubisco field originally looks a bit
like this where there's three typical
forms or classes of rubiscus that are
typically uh distinguished from one
another
um and there is a single evolutionary
interval which I've highlighted here in
red that basically separates all ruby
scores that now contain a small subunit
um from those that do not yet interact
with small subinet
um so coming back to the schematic I've
shown you earlier it this would
essentially be at the evolutionary
interval over which the interaction but
also the dependence evolved and for this
I have to also mention that basically
all the form 1 rubiscus so those that
you see at the tips of these blue plates
um all of those are already strictly
dependent on the small subbiness thus of
the interaction and the dependence
evolved in this interval
the second question we then wanted to
answer is whether or not we can create a
non-obligate rubisco hit or complex so
something which we presume must have
existed at some point in evolution
where basically rubisco can interact
with the small subunit but does not yet
strictly depend on it
and we presumed that this must have
existed at some point because it's
pretty unlikely that both the
interaction and the dependence on a
novel interaction partner Arise at
exactly the same time there likely was
an evolutionary intermediate even though
in all excellent forms of rubisco this
is now lost
third question was to then basically use
this non-obligate intermediate that you
see at the middle of this error here to
then quantify the impact of the small
subunit because now we're basically or
we would be in a position where we can
add the small Sub in it or leave it away
and then assess the biochemical
parameters of rubisco
and then the last question we wanted to
answer is why rubisco started to depend
on the small subnet so basically
following the arrow from the
non-obedient intermediate
to the dependents that you see all the
way on the right
and now for the next slide what we're
going to do is we're going to zoom in
into this phylogeny that you see on the
top right of the slide and basically
zoom in on this red interval of
evolution
so you're going to be seeing or what you
what you can see here is this last clade
of rubiscus that does not yet contain a
small subunit
um then the evolutionary interval
separating this from those that contain
a small Sub in it and then the two
distinct plates of rubiscus that contain
small subunits
now what we could do to basically answer
all the questions that we had or to try
and find the substitutions that cause
the interaction with the small subunit
and also the dependence on it is to just
directly compare existing rubiscus from
these two clades with one another
the problem with this is that these
sequences are much too Divergent they
only share about 30 amino acid identity
which in rubisco means that there's a
total of about 300 amino acids that are
different between proteins from these
two plates so it becomes really
difficult to actually
decipher which substitutions are causal
and you might be running into apostatic
problems where you need several
substitutions simultaneously to actually
see the effects that you're looking for
the first thing I set out to do is I
just basically looked in meta genomes to
see if I can find novel rubisco plates
that weren't really characterized yet
that break down this evolutionary
interval so that are a bit more closely
related to the first rubiscus that
contain a small subunit
uh here I got very lucky and I found
four noble cleats that weren't really
characterized at the time that I found
them
um that all break this evolutionary
interval and sit on the trajectory
towards rubiscus that contain a small
subunit
um looking into the meta genomes of the
organisms that encode these rubiscus we
found that all the green Clays down here
don't yet encode for a small subunit
whereas this great plate up here which
sits after the Divergence into these
canonical formula viscose that were
known previously they already contain a
small subunit
and now with this information at hand we
basically got these genes synthesized
them chemically and characterized the
resulting proteins in the lab
and for this we first set out to do in
vitro Stoichiometry measurements um
using Mass photometry
um just to assess when the
oligomerization changed along this
interval
uh just for I know this is a refined
seminar but just for those of you that
don't really know Mass photometry yet in
a very very broken down form you can
view a mass photometer like a nanodrop
for proteins
that instead of measuring a protein
concentration
it measures the mass of a protein
complex I can give you more details
about the methodology later if you want
but I figured since this is a refined
seminar this might be good enough
basically with this nanodrop-like device
with the mass photometer you're
measuring a video that looks a bit like
this where each individual Dot or each
contrast point that you see right here
corresponds to a certain protein mass or
protein complex mass that you can then
correlate back using a standard letter
or a standard curve and then the output
is a histogram that looks a bit like
this where on the y-axis you have the
number of events this is just how many
drops landed on the glass slide over
which you're measuring
and on the x-axis you have the inferred
molecular mass coming from a standard
letter
[Music]
and these types of histograms I will
show a lot in the coming slides however
not yet for these characterizations
right here
um these proteins we did all Quantified
by mass photometry but to make a long
story short we found that this light
green plate down here forms a simple
dimer of large subunits the clade
further up actually forms the first
plate of a viscose that is an OCTA
mirror of large subunits so eight large
subunits just like in all the form one
rubiscus
um and then for this great clade even
further up we found that it forms this
typical L8 asset complex composed of
eight large and eight moles of units
good so now that we've broken down this
interval what we could theoretically do
or is basically already propose an
evolutionary scenario of how this
canonical L8 asset rubisco form evolved
um in which the American ancestral
rubisco just evolved for a bit and
stayed the americ based on the
Stoichiometry of its descendants
then over this interval of evolution
um turned into an octamare for the first
time
and then in the next step of evolution
it
likely took on its L8 S8 form
so with this we basically pinpoint The
evolutionary interval over which the
small subunit evolved to be between sort
of this last green dot in the middle
right here and this gray ancestor
um which is the last common ancestor of
all canonical form one Ruby scores
now
again we what we could do here is we
could just take the accent sequences
that sit in these clades and compare
them to one another
however there was still too a virgin so
there were still about 220 amino acid
differences between the most closely
related proteins from these respective
plates
um and so what we decided to do instead
is we decided to use a algorithm called
or a method called ancestral sequence
reconstruction
um with which we wanted to focus on
ancestral proteins that basically
don't exist at the node at
am I lagging no I'm not lagging sorry um
that don't exist at a leaf of this
phylogeny anymore but instead at instead
add an internal node so basically it's
that I said that I don't have a pointer
here but basically at these green and
gray dots that you see in the middle of
this phylogeny right here and the way
this algorithm works is it takes all the
sequence information in this tree which
comes from a sequence a multiple
sequence alignment which you feed into
the algorithm to actually build such a
tree
and then it takes the relationship of
all the sequences so how related a given
sequence is to a given node within the
tree
and then uses a probabilistic model of
sequence evolution
to back calculate the most likely
sequence that would have existed at an
internal node to basically explain the
distribution of sequences that exist in
present-day organisms with the highest
likelihood
and so you calculate the sequences of
these internal nodes which represent
ancestry proteins that would have as
such most likely existed at some point
in evolution in the past
all right and so we decided to resurrect
two large subunits here this um sort of
Green Dot and then the gray dot that
sits further up
and to go along with the gray dot which
we presume to have already interacted
with a small subunit we also resurrected
the oldest inferable small subunit and
for this we did this entire procedure
again just with a different phylogeny
obviously built for the small subunit
but I'm sparing you all the details here
all right and then we basically
chemically synthesize these proteins
from commercial vendors or we buy them
from commercial vendors as genes produce
them in E coli and then measure those
documentaries
our expectations going in is that Uncle
so this is this green ancestor which
presumably existed before the small
Sabine had first evolved uh forms an
OCTA mirror of large subunits so eight
large subunits
which using mass photometry we could see
is true so we see one single or well we
see a peak corresponding to an octometer
and a smaller Peak corresponding to a
dimer and so that was true and then we
also expected that UNC LS ideally so
this this is the gray ancestral protein
which we presumed already interacts with
a small subunit would form an elite
asset complex with the small subunit or
the ancestral small subunit and using
mass photometry we could also show that
this is true and that it binds eight
small subunits and forms a stable
complex in solution
um just to complement this we also
solved Crystal structures of both
proteins and they do take on the typical
stoichiometries that we would assume
them to or that we would hope for
all right
um now there were two more outstanding
questions which we wanted to answer
um which is the first being does angel
basically this again this green
ancestral protein which existed before
the small subunit can this by chance
already interact with the small subunit
um here once again we used mass
photometry and what we did is we
basically just pre-incubated ankle so
purified protein with in this case a
four-fold molar excess of small subunit
and then looked whether or not we see a
shift in Mass on the Mass photometry
which we didn't
um so we concluded from this and other
pull down experiments
um that ankle cannot yet interact with
the small subunit
and the second question was whether or
not Uncle s so the gray protein further
up on the tree is already dependent on
the small subunit
um for this I'm showing you gels right
here which basically just where I've
loaded the crude and the soluble lysate
um in the portion that you're seeing
right here this is just ankle which
doesn't interact with the small
submitted yet
um and you see that basically in the
soluble lights that you have proteins
whether or not the small subunit is
co-produced
and then for Uncle s you see that there
only is a visible large subunit band on
the SDS page if you actually co-produce
the smart subunit
um the same is true in Native pages and
Western plots and also just in activity
and clarified lysates so on the right
you see that you only get activity for
Uncle s if you co-produce the small
subunit
um so from this we concluded that Uncle
s the gray protein is already dependent
on the small subunit
uh in a nutshell this means that we
found the evolutionary interval over
which both the interaction with but also
the dependence on the small subunit
evolved
which was basically step one of what we
wanted to find out
step two was then to try and see if we
can create a non-obligible hetero
complex this is basically the protein
that we ideally want to study in the end
um for this we had a bit of a closer
look at how separate these proteins are
now from one another so these ancestral
rubiscus that we're working with
um and there in our case separated by
still a quite big amount of substitution
so it's 95 substitutions and three
insertions overall that separate these
two proteins
um but luckily we had our Crystal
structures at hand and we could first
narrow basically our substitution set
that we were interested in
um down to those substitutions that
actually occur in proximity to the large
subunit small submitted interface
um because what we're what we were
trying to do now is we were trying to
engineer an interaction surface into
basically ankle
into this green protein
um so making it a tiny bit more like
Uncle s like the gray protein but only
at the apex of the complex
by introducing substitutions that
naturally occurred over this
evolutionary interval
um looking at those 14 substitutions
that localize in the large subunitive
small submitted interface a bit further
in the crystal structure we could see
that quite a few of these interactions
don't or quite a few of these
substitutions don't actually result in
amino acids that engage in any
meaningful interaction between the large
and the small subunit
um so we took this
um all of those substitutions that
didn't really engage in any interactions
we took those out of the set of
substitutions that we were interested in
this left us with seven to eight amino
acids that actually engaged in a direct
interaction between the large and the
small subunit
um and here I initially tried to
reconstruct the interface in single or
double substitution steps
which basically results in a plot like
this where I take ankle this green
protein right here I introduce all of
these single substitutions that are
listed on the left of this graph
um one by one I purify the protein and I
test by mass photometry whether or not I
see binding of the small subpoinette
um for single substitution constructs I
couldn't see any binding for double
substitution constructs I also couldn't
see any binding by Mass photometry
and then going into triple substitution
constructs I could first start to see
some small sub inequivalence being bound
to the protein complex which gave us
some hope
however this entire procedure turned out
to be quite tedious and I decided to
just introduce the seven
strongest binders or the seven amino
acid substitutions that result in the
introduction of an amino acid with the
highest buried surface area
at the same time which resulted in the
protein that we call L plus seven
and L plus 7 could actually bind eight
small subunit equivalents at very low
concentrations so at nanomolar
concentrations
um looking at the mass photometry data
of angle plus seven if I purify it in
the absence of a small subunit it forms
a nice octumer of large subunits and
then as soon as I add purified small
subunits this peak shifts we get binding
of eight small subunit equivalents to
the complex and the reconstitution of an
L8 S8 complex
again to further corroborate this data
we also solve Crystal structures of the
protein with and without the small
subunit
um and see that it basically behaves as
we would expect it to or as we would
hope
so now with UNC L plus 7 we found a
non-obligate rubisco hydro complex and
with this we now set out to basically
answer what the impact of interacting
with the small subunit is
um first obvious thing that we looked at
was the structure since we had to solved
the crystal structure we had hoped that
binding of the small subunit was would
allosterically alter rubisco in a way
that would basically make it obvious for
us to decipher a cause of the small
subunit
um however looking I mean what I'm
plotting here is the active side of
rubisco but over the entire protein uh
basically rubisco doesn't change at all
um aligning the structure of rubisco in
the L8 or L8 S8 form
results in an alignment that has a root
mean squared deviation of less than 0.3
angstrom so the the structures are
essentially identical
except for obviously an extra small
subunit being bound in the Allied S8
form
uh however we still set out to see if
there's any differences in catalysis
which would likely then stem from
Dynamic effects or effects that we don't
see in the crystal structure
and here we did actually see differences
so what we're comparing here is the L8
to the L8 S8 form so with and without
with and without small Sub in it
um of angle L plus 7 in both cases
we see slight differences in the
michelism kinetics of carboxylation a
slight decrease in the km for CO2 so
it's roughly a threefold decrease in the
km4 CO2 which comes along with a roughly
three to four-fold increase in the km
for iubp
so this was already interesting to us we
we assumed that this makes it a slightly
better carboxylase and we can also see
that it improves the catalytic
efficiency overall
um just by decreasing the km for CO2
which probably was very important in
environments where CO2 was limited for
organisms
um however what we were more interested
in at the time is to see whether or not
the small subnet modulates hibiscus
specificity Factor I've mentioned
earlier that Ruby Rose small subunit was
presumed to alter the specificity Factor
but now we could actually test it
and when we first went into this
experiment with L plus seven we saw that
there is a slight effect on the
specificity but it's not super dramatic
um specificity improves from roughly 23
um to 29 so there's about a 20 25
increase in specificity
uh however in Downstream experiments we
found an additional substitution which
makes this UNC L plus seven
um air plus eight sorry which actually
further increases this effect
drastically and the addition of the
small subunit then increases specificity
from roughly 25 to about 14.
um now obviously this probably doesn't
mean very much to people that are not
familiar with rubisco
but this is roughly the change in
specificity of going from
the the best rubisco that doesn't yet
interact with a small sub init
um to roughly the specificity of the
worst rubisco that interacts with a
small subinet so these are natural
rubiscus right here so we can basically
recapitulate the change in specificity
that we would have expected to occur
along this evolutionary interval with
a few substitutions basically eight
substitutions here to recreate The
Binding interface and then the addition
of the small subunit
importantly however the small subnet
alone is not the whole cause of
increasing specificity
but there are certain substitutions on
the large subunit that are required for
this change in specificity that also
importantly don't have an effect if the
small subunit isn't present you can see
this here on the plot where basically
you compare
the condition was no small subunit is
present between angle plus seven and
angle plus eight
cool uh one last thing that we asked is
whether or not the small subunit has any
effect on stability of rubisco
um and this was motivated by the fact
that basically all of the rubiscus that
are closely related to The evolutionary
interval that we care about uh stem from
thermophilic organisms
however when we just checked whether or
not it changes the thermal stability of
rubisco we saw that there is basically
no difference whether or not we add the
small submit
um rubiscus in this case is stable
either way but the small subunit doesn't
improve stability
so what we've done here is we've
basically incubated rubisco at different
temperatures then let it cool down and
then sh the remaining relative activity
and here we don't see any difference
however when we actually assay at
different temperatures so when we
perform the essay of like the catalysis
essay at higher temperatures we see that
the small subunit actually massively
stabilizes catalysis to higher
temperatures
um which allows catalysis up to maybe 80
degrees that wouldn't really be possible
without the small subunit anymore
and this is obviously highly interesting
to us because we think that small
subbing at first evolved in thermophiles
and this would have immediately opened
up new habitats to organisms that
suddenly carried the small Sub in it and
had the small Sabine interact with this
rubisco
so as a conclusion the small seven was
slightly highly beneficial when it first
arose
and it later enabled the adaptation to
Rising oxygen concentrations
all right and now turning to the last
question that we had is which was
basically why rubisco suddenly started
to depend on the small subunit when it
previously didn't
um and here we followed or started out
with a hypothesis which is called
hydrophobic entrenchment
um which basically states that anytime a
protein this can be any protein this
isn't specific to rubisco anytime a
protein increases its complexity by
either engaging in a new homo or
heterological memorization in this case
what is depicted is a
heterologomerization
you create a new interface
and in this interface you have a changed
constraint on the protein or on the
evolutionary sequence space that is
available to the protein
um in the absence of this interface for
example you might not be able to
accumulate hydrophobic amino acids on
the surface just because they would make
you aggregate
and then once this new interface is
created suddenly you are able to
accumulate these hydrophobic amino acids
just because
they are now shielded from the
environment through this new interaction
and this entire process can make protein
protein interactions become dependent or
become obligate just because now
suddenly you can't take this novel
subunit away anymore just because the
subunit that was previously able to
function in isolation and soluble in
isolation would now start to aggregate
after it has accumulated hydrophobicity
in the newly buried interface
so for this uh applying this to rubisco
we obviously hypothesized that this
so-called change of constraint is like
the largest in proximity to the small
subunit
um and so we focused on this time on all
14 interface substitutions that
basically occurred along the
evolutionary interval so instead of
building it up one by one as I did
earlier
we now decided to introduce all 14
substitutions simultaneously into Uncle
to create what we call L Plus 14.
um and this protein L plus 14
um basically became fully dependent on
the small subunit
um so what you see right here on the
left is uncle just without these 14
substitutions and there is no difference
in solubility uh in lysates whether or
not the small supplement is co-produced
and then in L plus 14 the presence of
the small subunit is essential
we then further tested whether or not
single substitutions can be responsible
for this by introducing all 14
substitutions individually
um and here we found that a serine to
trip the fan substitution so this this
is exactly the scenario that we proposed
earlier but basically a substitution
that goes from a hydrophilic to
hydrophobic amino acid
um causes a loss of about 75 percent of
uh insolubility just with a single amino
acid in a protein of 500 amino acids
and then if we combine these two
substitutions that have highlighted here
so this is e170n and the serenity drop
the fan substitution we actually abolish
all solubility in two substitutions
and it's important to note that
this loss of solubility is not because
the protein is inherently misfolded or
just unable to fold anymore but it can
always still be rescued by co-producing
the small subunit um so what you're
seeing here is a native page Western
blot where basically you see that if we
co-produce the small sub init in this
e170 and 70 tryptophan mutant we still
get soluble rubisco production so it's
not an inherently misfolded protein it
just depends on the small subunit for
solubility now
um and basically now we wanted to find
out how this setting to tryptophan or
how this double substitution construct
actually makes rubisco depend on a small
subunit
and luckily in our case
um the single substitution here retained
roughly 20 25 solubility
um so we could actually purify this and
study indeed like study the phenotype of
it in vitro
and here once again Mars photometry came
to our rescue in a way um because as
soon as I measured these proteins on
mass photometry I could see that there
was an additional sort of oligomer
observable that corresponded to roughly
two times the mass of a single L8
complex
and just for reference Uncle without the
serial defense substitution does not
show this higher uh higher molecular
mass complex at all
um and then thirdly I could also
basically put this protein into two
molar sodium chloride for example to
push the population of higher order
oligomers that we see
and as I've already sort of
schematically alluded to here in these
graphs we assumed that what we're
observing here is sort of this
fibrillation-like assembly of large L8
complexes of rubisco
um that would basically stack it
indefinitely
and we then looked at this using
negative stain electron microscopy which
confirms this fiber-like behavior and
then we're also lucky enough to solve a
roughly three angstrom cryoab structure
of this complex where it fibrilizes out
um you can also see this here in an
animated view where basically we have
just two repeats of this L8 complex
stacking on top of each other to form
this fiber interface
the fiber interface is driven by a
cation Pi interaction engaging into this
interaction with the tryptophan 437 that
we just introduced
um so this also perfectly makes sense as
to why we would now start forming these
fibers
and importantly if we try to model small
subunits onto this fiber um the space
between fibers is too small so there's a
big steric clash between interacting
octometers
which basically prevents fiber formation
as soon as the small subunit is bound
um so this also explains why solubility
is recovered if we co-produce the small
subunit
now one last thing that we wanted to
answer is whether or not the dependence
causing substitutions so for example the
serenity tryptophan is beneficial in any
way so whether or not it's beneficial to
the organism or for rubisco in general
to incorporate this tryptophan 437 which
makes it depend on the small subunit
and here I'm only showing Michaela's
kinetics without the small submitted
present but we basically see that
there's no different kinetics at all
this is actually an overlay of the two
different graphs which look pretty much
identical
um so we couldn't detect any any
advantages of incorporating the central
defense substitution even though it
makes rubisco depend on the small
subunit
um so what we conclude from this is that
basically over the course of evolution
uh you can neutrally accumulate these
substitutions that cause you to depend
on a novel subunit just because as long
as you've created this interface They
Don't Really incur a negative penalty on
the protein itself so they don't make
you
any worse adapted than you were before
the only thing that it causes is that
you now suddenly strictly depend on your
interaction to a novel interaction
partner
and then very last thing we wanted to
answer is whether or not more of these
sort of tolerated neutral substitutions
accumulate
um and what we set out to do here is we
basically just looked at our sort of
evolutionary interval again and so far
everything that we've done
was essentially taking uncle and
introducing substitutions that occur
along the interval into it
and now instead of going in that
direction what we decided to do instead
is we decided to take Angeles
and then take out substitutions to try
to recover solubility without the small
subunit
um here initially if we looked to take
out two substitutions those were the two
substitutions that made the angle 7
depend on the small subunit
but then in the next step we also
decided to take out a whole set of
substitutions which basically were the
substitutions that occurred in the fiber
interface which we've identified in the
cry uem structure
um and this turned out to also be 14
substitute substitutions coincidentally
um that are yeah basically sorry we've
also decided to take out these 14
substitutions that are in the fiber
interface
and now this is basically an SDS page so
showing the solubility of large subunit
rubisco in soluble lysates when the
small subunit is not co-produced
and you see there's basically no large
subunit band for Angelus alone
if you revert either single
substitutions or the double substitution
constructs you gain some solubility but
you don't get all the way there
and in order to regain full solubility
you would actually need to revert
basically all well in our case we
reverted all 14 substitutions in the
fiber interface but you definitely need
to revert more than the two
substitutions that it took to basically
first make you depend on the small
stuffiness
so solubility is only fully recovered
when reverting more than two
substitutions
all right and then one last thing is
that we basically realize that this
fiber interface that we were looking at
doesn't actually overlap with the large
subunit small submitted interface so
much
um so even though we reverted 14
substitutions the the large subunit
small submitted interface is still in
place
and this
um
fiber interface reversion construct can
still actually bind the small sub init
I'm looking at mass photometry of this
again the fiber interface version
construct forms a happy OCTA mirror in
solution
and when we add in this case a 10-fold
molar excess of small subunit we can get
this very typical shift and reconstitute
the Allied asset complex
so far this one was not unusual this was
as expected
however what was interesting is that in
this case now this protein this fiber
interface reversion uh strictly depended
on the small subunit for catalysis
um so basically you see right here this
the protein as soon as we add the
substrate ribose 15 bisphosphate we
would typically expect to see turnover
or production of three phosphoglycerate
and this didn't happen until we added
the small subunit
um and this is unlike anything we had
seen before just because in the past we
had characterized rubiscos
without the small subunit and then added
the small subunit and catalysis didn't
really change so much
um what this meant to us is that
actually over these 81 substitutions
that are that have occurred between
uncle and this fiber interface reversion
construct that we've just sort of
created and talked about
um a further set of substitutions must
have Arisen or accumulated that also now
make catalysis depend on the small sub
init as opposed to only solubility
um so the conclusion from this is that I
think it's interesting that basically as
soon as you alleviate a certain
constraint
um you immediately start accumulating
substitutions that erode for example
solubility or even the the ability of a
protein to catalyze its reaction on its
own
um just by accumulating these
substitutions because you can
um
now as a conclusion to all of this
rubisco small subnet improved catalysis
as soon as it arose at physiologically
relevant conditions mostly by decreasing
the km for CO2
it enabled the evolution of higher
specificity
um
we think that the small subunits became
essential mostly due to conditionally
tolerated substitutions so those that
don't really bring a positive effect but
just are tolerated
because they don't incur a negative
effect
and in general these accessory subunits
these novel binders can be important
sources of functional novelty as we've
seen that specificity for example
presumably probably cannot evolve in the
absence of the small subunit
um now as a small fun addendum just
because I didn't really get to talk
about the exact timing of all of this I
want to quickly mention when all of this
happened
so going back to this phylogeny that
I've been showing all over the slides
we know from previous Publications that
the diversification of Form 1 a b Ruby
scores
um so those are those rubrics goes right
here
um roughly coincides with the great
oxygenation event
um so the the point where the orange
arrow is pointing to right now is
roughly the timing when people think the
great oxygenation event first happened
uh which was about 2 to 2.5 billion
years ago
and as you can just basically see on our
phylogeny the rubiscus that we
investigated are older than this so they
presumably evolved and existed before
the great oxygenation event if these
inferences from previous Publications
are true
um this basically means that rubisco
started to improve its specificity so
its ability to to discriminate between
CO2 and O2
um before oxygen was really present in
very high concentrations or in
problematic concentrations
um
this could have two implications or two
there might be two reasons for this the
first one would be that there was early
localized oxygenation and rubisco just
happened to First evolve its more
subunit in an environment where oxygen
was present by chance before the great
oxygenation event so before the
atmosphere became oxygenated
um or this might be a form of
pre-adaptation
um where rubisco essentially recruited
the small subunit for its effect on
uh stability of catalysis at higher
temperatures that have gone into in the
results
and only then later started to use the
small subunit for its effect on
specificity
um yeah
all right and with this I'd like to come
to the end uh thank all my amazing lab
members and mentors most importantly
giorgor and Toby up
and then also Jan Suzuki Thomas
Prince season and Oliver Miller who've
helped massively with all the data
curation measurements and just have
assisted me
very much
thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you Luca for your informative
presentation if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for today let's get started
our first question is
do you think or know whether SSU also
underwent similar Progressive mutations
accompanying the changes in rubisco
right
um
I I don't know but I definitely think it
did
um it's it's shown in like much higher
up the philosophy of rubisco in in
plants for example that specific
substitutions in the small subunit still
have an effect on catalysis
and even just replacing a small sub-in
automotives that look very similar to
one another
um also affect kinetics of rubisco so
there certainly was selection on the
small subnet as well and I'm sure that
the small submit also co-evolved with
the large subunit to a certain extent
uh it just in this study we couldn't
really deal with that because it just
increased the combinatorial space too
much but this is certainly an
interesting question that should be
followed up on yes
great thank you our next question asks
are the mechanisms of how protein
protein interactions become essential
generalizable or confined to rabisco
I know I definitely think they are
generalizable
um basically if I can can I I don't
basically this this mechanism of
hydrophobic entrenchment that I've
showed earlier
um this should be completely
generalizable to any sort of protein
protein interaction protein protein
interface
um just because it's something as
universal as changing amino acids
towards hydrophobicity
um and since all organisms use the same
so or roughly the same code of genetic
code and roughly the same amino acids
but basically the same 20 amino acids uh
this should be generalizable yes
great thank you
um what was the role of mass photometry
and determining which substitution to
focus on or investigate further
yeah well basically I mean I think I
showed this in the talk but we
we massively relied on mass photometry
for
basically assessing the phenotype of our
substitution constructs
um and also for finding the basically
also the cause of the dependence onto
the small subunit so mathematology was
kind of essential and every time we did
any substitution the first thing we did
is to just throw down the mass
photometer
um also because it's so quick and easy
to just measure something
um so it sort of just became a go-to
practice to just
measure everything by mass photometry
before we actually move on with doing
any biochemical experiments with it and
sometimes this gave us really
fascinating insights such as for example
this polymerization that we could have
only found by Mass photometry
great and it looks like we have one more
question here today and it asks is the
approach of ancestral sequence
reconstruction universally applicable
what are determinants for its success
um
yeah so theoretically ancestral sequence
reconstruction should be universally
applicable
um there are
the problem is that you need a
well-sampled protein family ideally
um just because the more sequences you
have available the easier it is to
actually then
um
build a tree build a tree that is
actually that has enough granularity to
actually find nicely defined
evolutionary intervals that you want to
investigate
and the more information you have
available in terms of sequences the more
robust your reconstructions actually
become
um so all of this plays into uh this the
how successful a ancestral sequence
reconstruction Venture is going to be
but in theory it should be universally
applicable however another component to
all of this is that fast evolving
proteins might be a bit more difficult
to reconstruct
um just because
along a certain evolutionary interval
more substitutions were are likely to
occur
um in rubisco this is actually great
because rubisco is a rather slow
evolving enzyme
um so we don't really expect to see so
many substitutions along a certain
evolutionary interval even though we
were still dealing with 95 differences
between the two proteins that we cared
about
great thank you it looks like that wraps
up our q a session for today Luca do you
have any final comments for our audience
thanks for listening
not really no
great thank you again Luca for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor refine for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we'd go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labords will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye